hello and welcome everyone welcome back
this is the second interval of the third
applied active inference Symposium at
the Active inference Institute on August
22nd 2023
this is going to be another pact and
exciting interval and we're kicking it
off with Jean Francois Cloutier a
collective of theorizers First Steps so
JF thank you for joining and to you for
this presentation and if anybody has
questions for this presentation or any
of the others please just put it in the
live chat and I'll do it I can so thanks
JF to you
well uh thank you Daniel
um I'm a software engineer a company
called smart rent where I write software
for smart home systems and I also work
on a research project at the Active
inference Institute called the Robotics
and embodied project
my current focus is unsupervised
learning in active inference agents
in my presentation today which is titled
a collective of theorizers First Steps
um I'll first start with a brief recap
of the project
then dive into recent progress and then
I'll conclude with what I see as the
next steps of the project
well since 2017 I've been experimenting
with Lego robots and models of cognition
I do this for my own education
because uh like I think most of us I
understand something better when I build
it
what you see here is the my latest robot
model it's a Rover
it has a whole bunch of sensors and a
number of effectors actuators
um as a matter of fact Those sensors and
actuators can be understood as forming
the mark of blanket of my robot
last year I presented at the Symposium
about the history of the project
it's uh then status and
um it's ambitions
I presented a cognitive model that
implemented predictive processing from
an active inference perspective so they
were generated models there was
predictions there was prediction errors
and
um the these generative models animated
the robots so that they would roam avoid
obstacles uh observe their uh companion
and also in a very simplistic way build
a theory of Mind of the other robot they
could uh from observations
infer that uh the other robot had
defective food food being presented here
as a sheet of paper on the floor and
then would uh kind of try to track the
other robot to also get to the food
and and fun stuff like this the
implementation uh combined uh
multi-processing and functional
Computing there was nothing
probabilistic in the implementation
I thought maybe you would uh see them in
action that's what's presented last year
but just to get a sense of what they do
I have two robots here
um one named Carl and Andy I named them
before I knew I was going to present at
the conference
um so uh they benefited from a number of
training sessions they uh learned how to
um uh find which policies would achieve
their goals better than others and uh
one here on the left found the food
Brothers right away but got closer to
the pedestal uh where the beacon is that
simulates the scent of food
um
fear was getting into a collision and
then backs off in a hurry as we'll see
the other robot observes all this
sees the other the the the robot backing
up as being in a panic and uh decides to
share in in this emotion and backs up as
well so you know uh fun stuff
the um since from the beginning of and
implemented a different cognition models
but they all have in common the fact
that they Implement a Society of Mind
um so what is a Society of Mind a
Society of Mind is a concept by which
um the uh the mind is not a monolithic
uh structure but a composition of simple
actors independent actors that interact
with each other in simple ways
that the view of the Mind was put forth
by by Marvin Minsky
um 50 years ago so this is not recent
again what I presented last year was a
Society of Mind containing a hierarchy
of I call them cognition actors each
cognition actor is an independent
process
each one has a scope
um
a level of abstraction as well so for
example you would have a commission
actor that's concerned with the location
of food
and it would have beliefs and
perceptions about food location and
these would feed into a higher level
cognition actor let's say food approach
which is concerned about getting closer
to the food and so forth and so on these
connection actors communicate again in
simple ways this is a Society of Mind
and and they communicate by emitting
predictions predictions about the
beliefs of other cognition actors and
they communicate by emitting prediction
errors when predictions made about their
beliefs by others uh are inaccurate
that leads to uh connection actors
processing these uh prediction errors
and combining them with their own
predictions to create a an updated set
of perceptions that are synthesized into
beliefs and these beliefs lead to
um actions in order to eliminate
negative beliefs and Val or validate
positive beliefs
now it's from the interactions of all
these connection actors that seemingly
purposeful behaviors emerge
so that was successful but learning was
very limited this um this hierarchy of
cognition and actors uh was given was
pre-defined and the only learning that
um a robot would would do was to
discover which action policies tended to
be more effective
so clearly my robots are not monolithic
um active inference agents
um so the question is why would I
use a Society of Mind architecture well
because I I subscribe uh to the uh
notion that all intelligence is
collective intelligence
and and this paper makes uh the argument
uh quite cogently and I'm going to pres
I'm going to cite a number of papers
which were
important to the evolution of my
thinking this is one of them
this paper sees intelligence as a
process
and not a property it's a process
enacted by the interacting parts
as opposed to again a property of
individuals
so a Society of Mind is basically that
it's a it's actually a um a number of
interacting processes
um that together from which emerge
a perfectly intelligent behaviors now my
my own personal current definition of
intelligence is uh self-sustaining and
active sense making since making is
really important by autonomous agent as
system
in a dissipative and dynamic environment
and this guides
um all the work I do in this project
now if you want a um description a
detailed description of uh
where my project stood at the a year ago
there's a paper that was published that
I published on xenodome which you can
look up
now over the last year I wanted to move
away from a pre-built a given Society of
Mind and toward a learned Society of
Mind I wanted to see if
um I could program an autonomous robot
to evolve in Society of Mind through its
interactions with its environment
now one might think that programming
autonomy is an oxymoron
um it's it's it's it's it's a would be a
good point but I don't think it is
um if if the program I write and and
install my robots uh imparts uh
constitutive autonomy which is uh enable
the robot to constitute its own identity
and if it imparts adaptivity which uh
enable the robot to uh modify itself
from its interactions with the
environment then I think that
um uh the the robot uh will be truly
autonomous
now for uh autonomy to um
to exist inherently in the robot
something in the robot must be at stake
and in it's definitely it's in this case
it's the survival of the robots Society
of mind now
the physical structure of the robot is
not uh at stake it's survival is not at
stake unless of course it falls off a
shelf
but as I intend to
um have my robot develop its Society of
Mind from experiences I also expect that
if it fails that the Society of Mind
will perish in its attempt to to grow
and sustain itself
so that's what's at stake in in this
current and going forward in this
project is the robots survive the
survival of the robot Society of mine
and and this survival would be an
expression of being by doing uh the
robot need will need to act an interact
in its environment in order to uh
survive
now whatever sense it's going to make of
its environment will then be grounded in
this uh survival imperative in essence
the robot Society of mine will have skin
in the game
if this weren't the case then since
making would actually resides somewhere
else it would reside in in in in the
mind of the of the programmer in my mind
as I observe uh the robots but I would
like the sense making to be grounded
in the survival of the robot's mind
itself
so that's key
now what do I mean by an evolving and
growing uh Society of Mind so instead of
the given Society of Mind which I I
showed uh earlier
I want
um I want the cognition actors to uh be
created to connect with each other
dynamically through interactions with
the environment
um so I want an active uh
self-organizing
self-optimizing Collective of cognition
actors now is this feasible well that's
a big question
um in order to and trying to answer this
question uh I'll be
um also answering uh questions like what
must be given a priori and what can be
discovered well I already have elements
of an answer I know that the um the
sensors and the uh effectors and the um
the cognition the Primitive cognition
actors that wrap them will be given this
this will be like what you're born with
basically and there might be a um a
metacognition actor which uh role will
be to uh oversee and guide the evolution
of uh all other cognition actors but
that's that's my hypothesis
I can imagine a test environment for my
robot that will test its ability to
survive I can imagine for example that
um as the the robot moves around or
computes it it uses a Limited store of
energy it's simulated
and that store of energy is replenished
when the robot consumes food and that
would be by being on top of
pieces of paper colored pieces of paper
on the floor
um and I'm going to make sure that it
needs two sources of food in order to
survive right that would be represented
by a yellow paper and a green paper for
example so that to prevent the the robot
from just simply finding one one source
of food and just stationing itself over
it so the environment will also contain
obstacles so the robot will need to
learn how to navigate avoid obstacles
locate different sources of food get to
them and make sure that it it it
alternate between various sources of
food in order to survive and the um
Society of Mind that will evolve will uh
hopefully
evolve to successfully do this
else if it doesn't then it will um
shrink as resources uh disappear and uh
essentially uh die so that's what it's
at stake for uh this robot
now this effort employs a a number of
Frameworks
um
and by framework I mean a useful system
of concept and constraints that that
that guide uh the implementation
well there's obviously the the free
energy principle and the active
inference uh framework
um
however I see this the IC active
inference as and as if framework it
describes the what what must be achieved
in this case uh reduction of the agent's
uh variational free energy but it
doesn't guide me as to the
implementation how to build the robot
for this
um I need as is Frameworks and um I'll
be using uh two Frameworks one which
I've been using since uh the beginning
of the project which is uh the actor
model
uh the actor model uh views computation
as
um uh diversity of processes processes
that are independent have their own
private internal State and who
communicate with one another strictly
through messages
um yesterday in uh interval one uh Keith
Duggar uh presented on the actor model
and made the case that we should use the
actor model to implement active
inference agents well I wholeheartedly
agree with them
the other uh framework that I'm going to
be using is a special case of symbolic
AI called the app reception engine and
much of the presentation will be about
the opposition engine and its
implementation
so here's where we are uh is the project
is located at the intersection of active
inference as a domain the what and
Society of Mind as a architecture and
symbolic AI as a form of computing so
that's where the project is at this
intersection
you know so where to begin so I I want
to
um uh dive into uh
a more extensive form of learning and
the first step uh logically is to learn
how to predict so
um I want to
enable a single uh cognition actor we'll
start with a single cognition actor to
um learn how to make sense of its local
environment it's so-called unvelt and
making sense implies
as a at a minimum to be able to predict
incoming Sensations so it needs to learn
to predict
so
what will be given to a cognition actor
well a uh there will be a history of uh
Sensations uh broken into discrete units
of time
so time n minus 3 and N minus 2 and
minus 1 time n which is the the present
moment
so these would be remembered
observations
and then what we want to get out of this
is the ability to predict the next
incoming set of Sensations at time uh T
equals n plus one and plus two
and for this
to be able to predict uh future
observations we need some kind of
predictor function
that is learned from the remembered
observation
now this predictive capability can be
built in two very general ways one is
from statistics uh so doing pattern
analysis and and being able to predict
what's most probable which is the
standard Uh current machine learning
approach or we could predict from an
understanding of uh the observations by
developing a causal model
uh of these of what uh produce these
Sensations
and from this understanding uh predict
what rationally should be observed next
so this is all about
sense making
and now what is sense making how do I
understand sense making
um
well to rationally predict incoming
sensory inputs uh one must make sense of
them that's what making sense means to
me
um and to make sense of sensory inputs
means to derive meaningful experiences
from them it's not just data it's not
just pieces of data it's a there must be
meaningful experiences and by experience
I mean a conceptualization of the
sensations
and a unification of them in time in
space so making sense of these inputs
will mean to
produce meaningful experiences that are
conceptualizations and unifications of
the sensations now an experience is
Meaningful
if it is underwritten by a causal model
so the experience is is uh
is perceived as the consequences of a
latent generative model
a generative process that we have
modeled
and I want meaning to be inherent to the
agent and that only happens if the agent
is truly autonomous and if this meaning
is grounded in the survival imperative
as uh discussed earlier
so how does expansing work
how can that be put into computer code
surprisingly for this we refer to the
philosophy of Emmanuel Kant
a reverse engineering approach
um asking himself what must entities do
to achieve experience
this is akin to the free energy
principles high road which can be
paraphrased as what most organisms do to
maintain their existence so in manual
con uh we try to reverse engineer
um cognition
um asking himself what's the minimal
cognitive apparatus needed by an entity
to have experiences
and and that he he documented in his
critique of pure reason just a a little
parenthesis
um the the meaning of the title critic
of pure reason is not what I thought it
was
um it actually translates more closely
to the case for a period recognition
a critique is is a legal term is where
you make your case and pure reason uh we
translate nowadays is a priority
cognition
so
um
his work wanted to establish what must
happen to create an experience that's
coherent
that is Unified in time and space
um and through reverse engineer
recognition as a system that is both
complete and essential that is minimal
okay so let's let's
um I'm gonna try to give you the uh
posted uh postage stamp uh version of uh
uh Emmanuel Theory uh focusing on the
synthetic Unity of Apperception
well first of all there's the real world
which is outside of our direct
experience uh it's the nominal it's
forever hidden from us
um as an as is uh reality but we do uh
it it impinges on our sensorium and then
so we have a number of intuitions site
sound touch smell
um that are initially uh separate and
and then we need to uh Network them
connect them both in time and in space
in space
um uh is is sound and and and and the
site uh describing a single thing
um uh is one thing uh behind or uh
inside another
um and in time is this happening before
after uh something else and and then at
a higher level uh meaning is given to
these uh networked intuitions Sensations
uh via Concepts and and judgments rules
uh which are generalizations as to what
can and cannot be
um and this is what we experience
now it turns out that a con synthetic
Unity of that perception is
um
a blueprint for automating sense making
and it's kind of uh interesting I think
that 18th century philosophy would be uh
relevant to uh 21st century uh
technology development
and this is what happened and and and
was published uh by Richard Evans and
and all in the paper making sense of
sensory input where um they developed
the app reception engine
they took um synthetic Unity of our
perception as software requirements and
successfully implemented uh them into a
piece of software the app reception
engine and applied it to a number of uh
exercises
um and where they got a very good result
so the opposition engine is in um an
instance of machine learning it's
unsupervised machine learning and it
operates on very small data sets
um and generates uh human readable uh
generative models
and when I read the paper I realized
well that's exactly uh what my robots
needed
so what does an app perception engine do
well given a a sequence of observed
States
it uh finds a generative model
that can recreate past States but most
importantly predict uh future uh States
and the state is defined as a set of
simultaneous uh observations Sensations
intuitions
so
an appiseception engine
searches for a causal theory that can
recreate observations I say searches
because this causal Theory uh is not
determined by the observations
um it it has to be found it has to be
discovered but
once
it is found
then it can be validated against the
observations and see and see if it can
recreate them and augment them
into the future
as well as into the past
so what what is a causal Theory
a causal theory is is a logic program
that has a number of components
um they're in the causal Theory there
will be
um the objects and the predicates from
The observed uh relation so from the
observations we can extract what objects
were observed and what properties of
these objects were observed and maybe
what relationships and these these
objects were observed
that's the start then we have latent
object types objects and predicates so
we may want to imagine causal Theory
imagines a hidden objects maybe in types
of objects and maybe hidden uh
properties and relationships between uh
objects uh latent meaning unobserved and
given both of the observed and
unobserved um uh uh objects and and and
and and
predicates it
derives rules
first of all constraints on those
predicates what's permissible so for
example being in front of cannot uh a
cannot be in front of B N at the same
time B and at the same time behind B so
an object cannot be in front of another
and behind it so they're constraints on
predicates
And Then There are rules that apply to
any simultaneous sets of observations
what what uh they must conform to Then
There are rules that given a state will
infer the next state and then maybe some
initial state from which we can uh uh
run the causal Theory
so what makes a causal Theory Unified
well first of all it needs to be unified
in order to make sense of the
observation
there are various Dimensions so if a
causal Theory involves a number of
objects all these objects must be
directly or indirectly related there's
no object that just floats in space
totally independent of the other objects
so they must all be related
um so they're they're spatially Unified
all predicates that make up the causal
Theory like
on off behind in front they must be uh
constrained so that
um for example in front cannot be at the
same time as behind or that a light
cannot be both turned on and turned off
so there's there's some restrictions on
uh the predicates and that creates
conceptual Unity
and then the static Unity where all
simultaneous relations must satisfy
aesthetic rules and temporal Unity where
all the states must be sequenced by
causal rules
we'll see examples
so
let's
start with a an example here
of a set of observations what we are
observing are two lights
uh and the lights can either be at any
discrete Moment In Time
either on or off so here we have a
sequence of uh observations uh and One
Moment In Time
the first light was off and the second
night was on then
the first light was on the second light
was off
then both were on Etc
and I put the grape bars there
um to show that maybe the observations
aren't complete so on one stage we can
only see the second light or there may
be other lights or other objects that we
do not see but that's what we observe
so
you feed these observations
[Music]
um in discrete time
into the our perception engine
and the episode perception engine
searches for a causal Theory
that when applied to an initial
condition let's say that the light a is
off and light B is on it will create a a
trace of uh recreated observations
that um
cover is a superset matches the initial
observations and if this happens then
our causal theory is a good one
now the causal Theory May infer uh the
existence of hidden objects hidden
relations and whatnot it may actually
need to
okay so here's a an example of a causal
theory that is generated by my own
implementation of the app reception
engine because I I re-implemented the uh
the app reception engine as described in
the paper by Richard Evans and all
and um
I ran it on this the set of observations
about lights on two lights uh one on one
off at any point in time
and it came up with it found a result it
found the result in uh 64 seconds
it was a perfect match
and it um it actually invented a
relationship which is called tread one
um which we can that's that's imagine
that it's actually means connects to
and it found a static Rule and a causal
rule uh it said that a light is on
at any moment in time a light is on if a
light that connects to it is off
and it found a causal rule that said
um a light turns off if it uh connects
to another light that was also off
so that's how the the lights change over
time their status is on and off and it
came up with initial conditions that
said that well
a connects to first of all that there's
an object one a light called object one
that we don't see but is there we
imagine is there that a connects to it
uh the light object one connects to B
and the light B connects to object one
so that's the causal rule that it
discovered
now if we uh run uh this causal rule
produce a Trace
and as you can see the trace matches the
observation it adds an a new object so
the coverage being uh excellent the
perfect in this case and our causal
theory is a good one it's actually a
perfect one
it's no it's not necessarily the only
one though
so is this causal Theory Unified
so going back to uh Dr Khan's
requirement of synthetic Unity of that
perception not every causal Theory will
do though it may
predict correctly it may not be
meaningful unless it is Unified
well is it we've saw the fourth
Dimensions there's four dimensions of
unification is it especially spatially
unified well all our objects are
connected
directly or indirectly to each other
that's good
so we have spatial unification
do we have conceptual unification so we
have this new predicate we have two
predicates right uh Fred one which we uh
translate to connects to and then the
predicate that says uh whether the light
is on or off
well we have a constraint that says that
um
a a light can only be connected to one
other light so red one has a constraint
on it that says it uh
uh it it's it's exclusive so an object
cannot have spread one to two objects
you cannot connect to two objects that's
a constraint that was discovered and
part of the causal Theory and also uh uh
implicitly
um a uh the uh on uh relation of the
predicate as the value on or off and it
cannot be both at the same time so
it's conceptually Unified
is it statically unified or are the
rules of static rules obeyed well uh for
example the static rule would say that
uh given that b uh connects uh to a if B
is off then a must be on so if you look
at any uh place where B is off a is
going to be on and you could do that for
uh every uh other uh light and
relationships between lights so they
they all obey the static Rule and the
causal rule says in for example here
that if B connects to a
then if a was off then B must turn off
so if you look at uh B let's say e or B
was off
um
yeah if I'm sorry if uh B connects to a
and yes
and if a was off
B must be off so if a was off b b comes
off the next step so that's correct as
well
so statistically uh we are true and
temporarily we are true
we are unified and of course that uh we
get a thumbs up from uh Dr Kant
our causal theory is Unified thus makes
it makes sense of the observations of
the sensory inputs
now it's no accident uh that um
uh can't would be would figure in an
active inference project there is a link
uh between active inference and Kant and
it runs through the the celebrated 19th
century uh German engineer Hermann Von
ham Holtz
he was a disciple of Kant and he
developed the theory of visual
perception that operationalized Khan's
epistemology and in fact it anticipates
predictive processing uh in 1995 uh
Peter Dane and Jeff Hinton uh developed
the elmholz machine name is in his
Hunter
um and it is a type of artificial neural
network that's trained to create a
generic model uh from an original set of
data and it can account for the hidden
structure of the data
so there's a as you see there's a
there's a link which is uh discussed and
elaborated in this paper which is very
very interesting paper
all right so
close parentheses so we've looked at the
perception engine uh from the
perspective of philosophy
so uh
now let's look at it through the lens of
machine learning
um
we the observations that constitute a
training set it's a very small one
and the application engine is uh the
learning algorithm and what is learned
the output is a causal Theory
um so the the learning process is is
unsupervised logical inferencing and the
um the output is a human readable logic
program
so we see here that there's there's some
profound differences with uh the more
popular form of machine learning in that
the training set is really small
um that uh the uh the product of uh the
the learning the uh is actually a human
readable artifact in this case a logic
program
so this is the training set
um uh as as inputted lights
led a
turned off
at time one B turned on at time one a
term on at time two be turned off at
time two etc etc
so that's the training set
and you feed this into the um uh
Obsession perception engines algorithm
and out comes a uh causal uh Theory so
in in a little bit more details uh what
the algorithm is and does first it
extracts
um the uh observed object extend objects
the object types and predicates from the
observations so we have on we have
object a object B we have led as an
object type so that's all part of the
observations and that becomes part of
the extent vocabulary
then the opposition engine
imagines
uh unobserved objects types and and
predicates uh for the relationships and
properties and that becomes a latent
vocabulary so there's a a step of
imagination then using the combined
vocabulary you know the both the extent
and and latent vocabulary combined it
looks for a unified causal Theory a set
of constraints rules and initial
conditions that uh obey the um the rules
of
um the constraints of uh synthetic uh
Unity of our perception
um once it has this causal Theory and
with initial conditions it applies the
causal Theory to these conditions and
produces a Trace
uh it recreates observations if you want
and and augments them and and extends
them to the Future
uh now it looks at this trace and
Compares it with the initial
observations for coverage and decides if
this is a good causal Theory or not then
it also looks at the causal Theory
complexity how many rules how complex
are the rules
Etc and um measures for complexity so if
we have a choice between two uh causal
theories of equivalent coverage
um the app reception engine will uh
select the least complex one using
Occam's razor
now if you look at this algorithm you'll
see that the the the boxes in green are
um not uh deterministic that's this is
where search happens we can posit
different kinds of objects we can find
different kinds of rules so this this
was this is where search happens
now
our perception is implemented using
logic inference actually it uses uh
three forms of logic inference there's
the one that we're more familiar with
which is uh deduction where given rules
and causes we we infer the effects then
there's uh induction where given causes
and effect we look for the rules this is
what science does right looking for
rules that would account for uh effects
given the causes
then there's abduction where given the
rules and given what we observe the
effects we're looking for the causes in
this case we're looking for the latent
objects the latent or relationships
between these objects
and then you can combine both abduction
and induction where you're given effects
essentially observations and you're
looking for both causes and rules which
is what the app reception engine does
and this is where in the um in the
algorithm uh these kinds of inferences
uh are at Play
so positing latent objects that's that's
a form of abduction
uh imagining causes finding the rules
well it's clearly a a form of induction
and then applying the rules to uh uh of
a causal Theory to
um some initial conditions to create a
trace well that's that's deduction when
we have the causes the initial
conditions we have the rules causal
Theory and then we produce a trace the
effects so that's that's deduction so
the app reception engine uses all forms
of logical inference
and and now just a reminder that um the
output of the perception engine that is
what is learned is actually human
readable uh you may want to compare that
to a a large
array of floating points uh produced by
a traditional the more uh popular form
of machine learning nowadays so here
this is what's actually produced by the
app reception engine as it runs on a set
of observations it produces
um a logic program that is human
readable the only when you look at it
the only thing you need to to kind of
guess is what does the what what is
meant by pred one and if you think well
maybe it means connects to maybe the
lights are connected underneath uh a
board out of sight of um
of the Observer
but finding a unified causal theory is
hard so we have to guess what the latent
objects and predicates are what what are
the hidden uh lights what are the hidden
relationships between lights and we have
to discover what constraints might apply
on the predicates
um and what are the initial conditions
from which we want to recreate a trace
uh what are the static rules that apply
to a simultaneous observations and then
what are the causal rules that given uh
observations at time T will predict
observations at time t plus one
this this is hard
as a matter of fact it's a non-polar
polynomially hard uh the search space
grows exponentially with the size of the
input which is the the the the the size
of the uh accident extent and latent
vocabularies and
so just like in chess you can't uh
predict to the end the consequence of a
move because of common neural explosion
with the perception engine you cannot
systematically Traverse the entire space
of possible causal theories to find a
good one because it's impossibly large
so the job of the aposition engine is to
find a causal theory in a ridiculously
large haystack
how to do this
uh in my implementation I follow the uh
the the the recommendations in in uh and
and I follow also the implementation in
Richard Evans paper by breaking the
search space into uh chunks
first I there's a region and the region
says
um so how many latent object types
objects and predicates will we allow so
what is the limit of imagination of the
cognition actors that is trying to uh
perceive a causal Theory what are the
limits of its imagination and within
that region
um of bounded imagination
um we
carve it into templates where we say
okay we're going to use these latent
objects types these latent objects and
uh so basically what vocabulary specific
vocabulary we're going to be using we're
going to use object one we're going to
use object uh thread one on top of the
uh observed on uh predicate and observed
A and B lights and we're going to set
the maximum complexity on the rules and
see if within uh we can find causal
theories that fit this template so this
is a carving up of the search space
and having broken the search space into
regions and templates
uh
we have Scopes in which to apply
heuristics now why heuristics because
the systematic traversal and it cannot
be done in reasonable time there's just
too many uh candidate causal theories to
to look at to find a good one so we use
heuristics we find
we we find ways of maybe getting to a
good solution faster at the risk of
missing it but at least uh we'll have an
answer or no answer in a reasonable
amount of time and there's a number of
of heuristics that I have implemented in
my implementation of the perceptron
engine
well there's time boxing at some point
you'd spend no more than this amount of
time looking into a region or into a
template
oh there's multitasking well the problem
is actually as they say embarrassingly
parallel you can explore multiple
regions and multiple templates in
parallel and so make good use of a
multi-core uh computer
uh you want to make sure you don't
repeat yourself so you don't want to uh
Traverse the same region uh twice or
look at the same puzzle Theory twice
you want to satisfy you may be a good
enough theory is just fine we don't want
to look for the perfect one necessarily
we may not have time
um you want to fail early if you're in a
region where nothing good is found you
may want to leave it uh quite quickly at
the risk of maybe not finding the a good
one that is just over the horizon but
you want to be impatient
you want to throw the dice you may want
to kind of mix it up so that every time
you run the Apple Citron engine on the
same problem uh you may find a solution
a a different solution first
um you want to uh go for The Simple
Solution first you may not want to try
everything to sample sum you want to
start with the the easiest uh part of
the the search space first be judicious
and so forth and so on and most
importantly be selective so reject any
uh causal theory that would fail the the
the constraints of unity of our
perception
with all these in place
um the running my interpretation of the
app reception engine gives pretty good
results so here I I did a run this is
not cherry pick that's decided to do one
a series of seven runs uh and collect
the data and show it and in this run I
set up the app position engine to only
accept a perfect causal Theory one that
would uh produce a trace that totally
covers the observation so and I did
seven runs uh the first one succeeded
founded in four seconds
uh the second one it took 102 seconds so
there's there's some randomization in in
the order in which things have searched
is luck is involved as I said
um the third one one second that was
that was pretty cool the the the fourth
one wall took 204 seconds
and then 96 12.99 so uh what a a good
distribution here
now I said okay I'm gonna I'm gonna run
the perception engine again on the same
uh training set that I showed earlier
those two lights
but this time I said um I'm gonna be uh
I'm going to accept the theory that has
at least that has at least 80 that has
85 or more coverage so it it predicts it
it it recreates the the the observations
well enough but not perfectly and I uh
time boxed it to 30 seconds so you have
30 seconds to find It Go
um the first run it signed a a causal
Theory with 75 percent uh accuracy uh
immediately then the same accuracy same
coverage 10 seconds 11 seconds it hit 80
29 seconds it found a perfect one then
11 it found 87 coverage and stopped
right there that's good enough 75 again
100 is the first one it found above 85
in 18 seconds and 75 zero seconds so a
good distribution again so we're getting
into a reasonable times we're not
talking about hours here we're talking
about seconds and I'm I'm hoping to um
do further optimizations and bring it
down to something even smaller so that a
cognition actor can say uh uh I want to
make sense of these observations
uh
query the perception engine and get an
answer a causal Theory within uh maybe a
couple of seconds That's My Hope
now something interesting sir it so
happens that what makes it hard for the
app perception engine to find a good
causal theory is formally equivalent to
what makes cognitive science as a whole
hard and that's this paper here makes
the case and proves the case quite
quotiently
um so uh
cognitive science wants to find models
functions or algorithms that
explain account for
um situated behaviors so you you feed in
uh you feed into this this the cognitive
science machine
um pairs of situations and behaviors and
you want to come out of it a a model an
explanation a a function or an algorithm
that accounts for it
well the the paper makes the case that
if if if the explanation is is to be
bounded in size then the the the the the
problem is computable
but is not tractable in the Senate
meaning that it's come naturally
explosive but once you have a solution
it is uh computable and tractable to
verify that the solution is good that it
accounts for the um the uh the data that
you're trying to understand well this is
this is equivalent formerly equivalent
to what the app reception engine is
doing
um
my implementation was done in prologue
uh I will not go into the details it's
about a thousand lines of prologue I'll
just say that prologue is a programming
language uh that use uh deductive
inference as its model of computation
with backtracking
um so essentially it searches it
searches for a solution and will
backtrack if it took the wrong
um Branch if you want it and and and
we'll look for a different way of
satisfying a a uh a line of the program
um so let's just say that it it makes
traversing a search space uh it gives we
get traversing the search points for
free when we program in prologue I won't
go into any more details but you can see
some prologue code here and it's uh the
fun thing is that um a a prologue
program is akin to a logical description
of the problems trying to solve
I think it's very cool
and the
prologue environment was augmented by
something called constraint handling
rules which is an extension to prologue
that adds abductive reasoning so
basically in the program you can say
assume this is true until proven
otherwise and the uh the uh the rules
the CHR rules
um are there to uh verify if it can be
proven otherwise
so um again I'm not asking you to
understand this quote at all but I want
you to realize that this code is the
code that actually executes a causal
Theory
um both the static and causal rules to
build traces it is that small it's it's
very powerful so combining prologue in
CHR
um I found extraordinarily uh powerful
I'm very excited about it I'm a
programmer
next steps
well next steps now that we've solved uh
individual learning uh by cognitive uh
actors
well I want to move to uh beliefs from
uh from the sensations and to policies
to validate or eliminate beliefs
um a lot of these beliefs actually fall
out of our perception latent objects and
latent relationships and properties are
can be considered by as beliefs then
there are other kinds of beliefs that
can be uh obtained from uh what's been
not perceived
um they'll be introspective beliefs uh
that uh uh communicate
um how the cognitive cognition actor is
doing in terms of competence
predictionary rates
um how well uh it's um its our
perception is doing is and whether it is
uh engaging with other cognition actors
is it relevant
I will have feelings which will provide
normativity to these beliefs so if uh
feelings are signals of uh risk to
homeostasis loss of resources physical
damage uh too many prediction errors so
that's hunger pain and fear uh and
feelings will take beliefs over time
and
tainted beliefs and Norm
good beliefs bad beliefs will want to be
eliminated or validated through policies
um that will be synthesized by the
cognition actor
and each cognition actor Will emit uh
make available to others
um its API what what predictions can be
made about the beliefs of this cognition
actor what actions uh are available to
others to be uh uh asked of the
connection connection actor
and then as cognition actors uh uh
connect to one another
uh as the connection actors formed the
um belt of other cognition actors
then uh the accommodation actor will be
able to predict the beliefs of others
will be able to
compose policies made out of actions
that are implemented by other cognition
actors
and eventually
um we'll have a Society of Mind which is
a bunch of intersecting uh uh Boon belts
so um that's uh it
um so I I see what uh the Society of
mine is a complex system uh of
collective theorizers
and I'm gonna try going further this
project to answer the question if uh
Collective of theorizers can
self-organize to actively sustain itself
so thank you uh to the active efforts
Institute for inviting me to present and
for providing a home for this project
and for the constant support and
encouragement
I'll see you later on Discord thank you
awesome thank you JF just to conclude
the session I'll I'll read two questions
and let's maybe address them in an
upcoming Robotics and embodied meeting
so if you're excited about this project
certainly we all are and about symbolic
active inference join the Discord and
participate in the Robotics and embody
it but I'll drop these two questions
from David Williams in the chat who
wrote One how important is conducting
this work in Real World versus
simulation and two what tools or
components are missing in the robotics
toolkit to make this research easier and
better I know those are things you have
a lot of thoughts on so I'll look
forward to uh discussing with you more
thank you JF
thank you peace
all right
see you